if you think this way you're going to be
a loser you're never going to make it
because there's no maybe I've seen the
guys training with me also 4 hours a day
5 hours a day but they look like there's
a lot of things in life that are
difficult and you have to ask yourself
the question right off the top you know
are you going to be one of those guys
that are going to go and back off every
time something is difficult or do you
want to be one of those guys that says
look doesn't matter if it's easy or
difficult I'm going to go and Crush
through it today I just need to sleep in
it's said this country was not built on
sleeping in so let's get up in the
morning and let's get on that bike and
let's do some exercise and don't even
think about it don't look at your email
you're going to go and accomplish
something really special and be the best
in anything in the world and you think
you can do it without working you make a
big mistake you can be the greatest do
it go for it hey it's EV Carmichael and
I watch these videos every day because I
need them for motivation being around
successful entrepreneurs every morning
helps me believe that I can do great
things too it's like you're morning
coffee but for your goals kickstarting
your day with a blast of positivity so
here is a challenge for you try watching
One video every morning for the next 30
days and let's find out together if they
help you do great things too if you're
in leave a hasht believe in the comments
below so I can celebrate with
you I felt many
times that I'm not a disciplined
person but people always sister say oh
it must take so much discipline every
day to get up and every day you were in
a gym at 7:00 in the morning and you
worked at at 9:30 in the morning and
then you went to college after that and
then you went this and this and you
worked on construction I was like
looking forward to getting up in the
morning and looking forward driving to
the gym and working out two and a half
hours and then going down to the beach
and taking a run in the deep sand and uh
getting some cardio work done and all I
said I was looking forward to it it was
not like oh my God I have to do another
workout yes you do that when for
instance sometimes people go to the gym
and the doctor says you know you should
go to the gym and you should work out
because otherwise you know I see some
problems coming up high cholesterol and
body fat and this and that and you're
going to go and wipe out you know 10
years younger than you want
to if there's ever the right time to
wipe out but I mean in any case so that
person you can see in the G
is there and they just they do their
reps and they do their sets and they're
not really into it you can see there's
no life in the eyes you know what I'm
saying where it's like they really they
grab the weight and they do those sets
and they get the pump and they feel good
they put the weights down and get the
next heavier weight and then do this set
and so that's really fun but that person
is kind of like a vegetable in a way
they just cruise around in the gym they
sit on the life cycle and they just
pedal away and when you say to them is
is why why do you work out they have no
answer then eventually they say well to
be honest with you the doctor told me
that I should get in shape that's better
for my health to bring my blood pressure
down and my cholesterol down and my body
fat down and all so they're not really
so I say to them always I said you know
what you should do is you should just
pick a goal that you can
chase they would say like what I say
what how much do you weigh mhm I'm
weighing lb and I want to I want to
lower my body fat body weight I said
well why don't you pick a go like you
want to go down to
170 and it it is now
March and by
August when you go to the beach you're
going to have a Slimmer waste less body
fat and you look leaner and you can be
proud of your
body as it pick that go oh that's a good
idea I say write it down and then then
write down the sets you have to do to
get you there and the amount of reps you
have to do and the amount of life cycle
that you have to run and regular bicycle
and running that you have to right all
of this down and then you mark it off
every day you mark it off that's what I
did the me was really the that feedback
that I see a line being crossed that
means one was said was done it was a
satisfying kind of a thing the line was
crossed off the next line was crossed
off and so I tell people that and then
they just say oh my God this is yeah
yeah I'm going to do that that is such a
great idea then they come back to me
like a few months later and they say
this worked oh it was unbelievable it
worked it was fantastic and it really
gave me a purpose see so that's what
it's it's why it's so important they
have a purpose when you do things have a
Clear Vision when you do things because
then you don't have to look at it kind
of like I have to be really disciplined
to do that or I have to make certain
sacrifices to do that because then it
just drags you in De direction and you
just do the work I had this need of
coming to America I mean when I started
learning about America at the age of 10
and we we got geography lessons and and
uh learned about uh America and about
the in so the first photographs I
remember in those uh photos in the
textbook but also in Super 8 mm film
footage that they showed in the
classroom you know about the Gordon Gate
Bridge and the Empire State Building and
the the six Lane highways and all I said
what am I doing here in Austria I me
this little road I want to go over there
I want to be part of the the big deal
and so I had always this desire and I
felt like that the only way ever would
get to America because in those days it
wasn't common that you buy yourself a
ticket that no one could afford that so
I had to kind of accomplish something
big that takes me to America and then
when I I read about this guy re Park who
won missed the universe three times and
then became a star in Hercules movies
and then was in Italy filming and then
in Hollywood filming I felt that could
be the dicket I should become Mr
Universe I should become kind of a
second Ridge Park of course no one
really bought into that my parents
thought I was totally insane and um I
remember that uh I I hung up pictures up
my bed um you know for for inspiration
pictures of re Park in his posing Trunks
and all that my mother was so concerned
she called the the local do doctor and
she had him analyze the wall because she
thought that there's something terribly
wrong that I have naked man above my bed
and all of my buddies had women hanging
above their bed and so she was concerned
about that and uh but they just I think
that the my parents really thought that
there was something terribly wrong of
being that driven you know because I
would come home at lunchtime and then
instead of having lunch I would do 200
sit-ups and at night I would go to the
stadium and I would be lifting weights I
will come home at 10:00 at night and
there will be contined lifting weights
so it was like one of this Insanity in
the military I will continue lifting
weights no matter how the training was
and how tough the basic training was I
would always then lift weights
afterwards and as a tank driver would
have on the side of the tank in the
toolbox I would have my weights my
bubles and my dumbbells and my exercise
bench and everything there in order to
be at any given time if we stopped
driving the tank and Maneuvers at two in
morning I will be able to pull out my
weights and again lift for two hours my
weights so so I was really a fanatic
about the whole thing but it's the only
way you really get where the way I I
succeeded because uh uh I became at the
age of 20 at the youngest Mr Universe in
London in the history of bodybuilding
because the youngest before then was re
Park the guy was talking about with the
age of 24 but I became the youngest with
20 but it was because I was like so
serious about the whole thing and it
worked worked with the age of 21 after I
won my second Mr Universe title um I got
an invitation from Joe weeder who was
the publisher of all the muscle
magazines in America and also the person
that had the biggest Warehouse of weight
training equipment and had food
supplement companies and all this and he
brought me to America and so there it
was I mean 6 years after my dream
started I was in America don't be afraid
of failing because there's nothing wrong
with failing
in you have to fail in order to climb
that ladder there's no one that doesn't
fail Michael Jordan said in one of his
interviews when they said you're
unbelievable you're the greatest
basketball player of all
times I mean tell me about that and he
says well you just mentioning the
successes but he says for me to become
the greatest basketball player I missed
9,000
shots when I was playing basketball at
the NBA
games so during the games that he was so
successful he missed 9,000
shots does it make him a failure no he's
one of the greatest basketball players
of four times but he
failed 9,000 times do you get it
we all
fail it's okay how would you suggest
people think of never think small or
what stories come to mind that from your
life
exemplify that well just just a very
beginning I mean for me to go and say I
want to compete in the junior Mr Europe
competition rather than just in the Mr
Austria competition it would I trained
just as hard as everyone else in the gym
their goal was just smaller they said I
want to be Mr Austria and I said I want
to be Mr Europe so I'm going to start
with Mr junior junior Mr Europe the best
buil man of Europe I'm going to go to
this competition and I was thinking
bigger and I was training as hard as
they were everything was the same but
then when I won that competition because
I had a very clear Vision that's what I
want to win that immediately launched me
into getting
a job to become a trainer in Munich in a
bodybuilding gymnasium now imagine
how in heaven is that you're young
bodybuilder you're 18 years old you just
W your first International competition
you win some local competitions in
Austria you win some powerlifting
competitions some weightlifting
competitions but now you are junior Mr
Europe and you have this Trophy and now
you're getting a job to train in the
second biggest gym in Munich so that was
like absolute heaven so with 19 I
started training become the trainer in
the gym so now I had the
opportunity to train day and night if
when I wake up because I was sleeping in
the gym I was waking up and I was
training I was taking a nap in the
afternoon I was training I was going to
sleep before going to sleep at night
after dinner I was training I was
training day and night so this is a
dream but it was all because I thought
big they were still stuck working for
for some bath house in Austria or for
the government or being a trash
collector or being a teacher or
something like that they were still
stuck in the same job I was already
moving on to Munich and I was already a
trainer in a bodybuilding gymnasium
making this the launch pad to America
which was my Ultimate Dream so this is
what I'm saying so it didn't take more
work to think big it's just thinking big
just thinking big makes you bigger and
what my point is is it takes just as
much effort so I my whole and I learned
again from bodybuilding from that kind
of thing I learned that don't hold back
so when I went within age of 19 I was
the youngest Mr Universe competitor I
competed in a Mr Universe contest and I
I placed second I placed runner up so
that a year later I went back with the
age of 20 and one Mr Universe the
youngest Mr Universe ever but this is
all because I was was thinking big I
wasn't saying oh maybe in a few years
from now I go there or I shouldn't go
there right now or something or it's too
early or is and then it's just thing
right way I'm going to go for the second
Mr Universe next year I'm GNA go to
America I'm GNA go and make Joe weer
aware of me and you know make sure that
I win another competition and all so I
was driven bigger and bigger and bigger
and even when I got into acting I didn't
look at it as kind of like I'm going to
get some character roles I wasn't
interested in character roles I want to
be another Steve Reeves or re Park they
were the stars of the Hercules movies
cint East would just a star with always
cleaned Eastwood you know in a fist full
of dollars cleaned Eastwood in a dollar
a few dollars more cleaned Eastwood and
in in know in this movie whatever it was
it was like I that's what I wanted
Charles Bronson I want to be like
Charles Bronson I want to be like War
Bay I want to be like this guys they
were the top stars and that's what I saw
myself and they said well this ladder is
very hard to climb
up I said well then I build my own
ladder I built my own ladder and then I
know exactly how to get up there that's
exactly what I did I created my own way
of getting up there also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quot quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there think big because then you're
going to get big then you're going to go
and Achieve big things that is the most
important thing you know we don't
achieve big things by accident so shoot
for the top shoot for the sky shoot for
the you know uh for the stars the bigger
your goals are and the more outrageous
they are or especially if someone else
has never done it yeah then the people
will always say this is crazy this will
never happen you cannot do that it's
impossible in all those things and so
you know we we have heard all the
naysayers and everything like that and
uh you just cannot pay any attention to
that because it's just the way it is and
so I'm I always feel like if I can see
it and if I can believe it then I can
achieve it how you've been able to
maintain a grounded ego because you're
very much a person of the people you
like staying connected with people
you're all about people um but for a
different version of Arnold that ego
could have run rampant and imploded your
life so it could have you're absolutely
right it could have the only thing is
that I think maybe would help me is is
that I never really felt that I have
arrived to be honest with you not in
bodybuilding not in uh I mean I
pretend and I do the big Spiel right you
know I'm the
greatest exactly I do all of that yes
but I mean in reality I feel like when I
work for instance on the
movie I really don't feel like I it's
any different than being a
plumber you know I go to work they put
all the schms on and the makeup and I'm
sitting there like an idiot at 5: in the
morning so that I'm ready at
8:00 and and and then you go out and you
you do your work do your scenes then you
go and have your lunch and you know it's
it's like the same it's like going to
Brook and then going back home I don't
see myself as a star I just see myself
as a work
and uh so when people then
say you're so nice you eat with the
crew I feel like I'm the crew I'm just
one of them right we all trying to make
a good movie and so it's like I never
really
feel out there I don't look at myself as
making myself
vulnerable I think that have learned
over the years that it's always good to
be able to express yourself and to say
you know whatever is on your mind and to
be honest because I think that we can
learn much more for ourselves and other
people can learn from you if you are
honest you know if you fail in something
it's much better for me to say I failed
in this because if I
recognize it's like in German we were
saying you know
selfness is the best to best WR meaning
if you realize that you're falling short
in something if you realize that you're
bad in something or that you failed in
something the best way to to do is is to
recognize that that's when you can
really improve because if you ignore it
and if you say no that was not that was
not me I it was costed because of this
and that if you find excuses for your
failures then you would never learn and
you would never grow and to me it's all
about growing because
remember I see the mind and the way our
brain works the same as our muscles now
you and I we worked out together so we
know that the more we pull on that
bar the more resistance we give our
muscles the better it can grow because
the more will respond with the head is
the same way your character is the same
way the more you give the character your
head and the Brain resistance the more
you make it struggle and the more you
make it suffer and the the more you've
experience defeat and all of those kind
of things and recognize it and then try
to repair it again the stronger it will
get I think the biggest mistake is that
you go to the
gym and you go through the
motion but you don't really have your
mind inside the muscle so when you do a
bicep curl I can't just stand there like
this yeah you can I've seen the guys
training with me also 4 hours a day 5
hours a day but the looked like and why
did they look like is because they
didn't concentrate they did the same
exercise but they went they stood like
listen and they looked
sideways kind of like they were bored
because they didn't even know why they
were training that they were not inside
the bicep or inside that lat when you do
the rowing and you pull back and you
Flex the the the the upper back and the
center back and then you let it down and
you stretch it you think about that the
wing is coming out now or like a curtain
is opening up you we always thought
about the curtain right this is when we
did our L spread so you got to think
about those things when you do calf
races and I do my donkey calf races I
got to be inside the calves and to make
them split to make them open up when
those guys sit on top of it you know
first three guys then I have one guy
jump off and with two guys then I have
another guy jump off there there's one
guy left and on my back sitting and
doing donkey races you know some people
looked at this this guy do some kingy
singing but anyway there was something
else the strange as they didn't know
what we were doing but I tell you you
got to be inside the muscle the same is
when you do chest I mean when I when I'm
finished with a bench press immediately
I step in front of the the mirror and I
flex I hit the shot I want to see
everything how it works right and the
same is with the cable crosses when you
do afterwards cable crosses I want to
always see what happens how do you in
your own world fight back against all
the negativity that we
see well first
I think the most important thing is that
we
realize that uh the human
brain functions a certain way mhm and
that you cannot go and wipe that
out you can fight against it and you can
help it but you cannot wipe it out so
don't get mad about it like we know
forever bad news sells better mhm so the
media automatically will show you much
more kind of like a
car accident where four people got
killed yeah rather than the car accident
where four people were saved so I mean
it's just that's just the way it is and
so they the media will always report
because the media has to have people
tune in so it's not that the media is
negative and that they are always
feeding us negative stuff it's just they
know that the people love to watch
negative stuff right so so this is why
this is this this thing that you have to
understand that people are more
attracted the negative than the positive
and so therefore we have to make an
effort to kind of confront that and kind
of work against that and and so when you
see for instance on social media
everyone attacking each other and being
really negative then I came out with my
newsletter and with my kind of thing
which now everyone calls the positive
corner right you know it's kind of like
oh if you want to have something
positive okay we just read the negative
news let's switch over to something
positive and let let's look what
schnitzel has to say you know and so
then they read my newsletter and they
read the positive thing and so my book
is about that because I always felt I
understand the negativity out there and
I will always be positive because I'm
just a positive person and the reason is
also because I have so much to celebrate
the word selling
sometimes comes off
sleazy so that's why I can call it
promotion or communicating or whatever
you call it and the point of it
is that you can have the best product in
the world but if no one knows about it
what's the point of the product I mean I
would like I'd like to
know uh for instance if there is someone
out there that does a heart surgery
or valve replacement without having to
have open heart surgery yeah but if I
don't know I would just go to the
hospital and say I want to have open
heart surgery and want to get the valve
replaced but if I know because they
promoted it well I can go now and call
that expert and then go so this is why I
think it's it's it's so important when I
came to America there was in my blood
now selling and and and communicating
and promoting so when I did my I
remember my book promotion ior that
education of a
bodybuilder Simon and chst wanted to
have it you sell 100,000 copies mhm so I
said whoa I want to have it on the
bestseller list I don't no bodybuilding
magazine was ever on the bestseller list
forget about that I said well I said
let's give it a shot how many cities do
we go and promote the book and he says
well here's six cities I I suggest and
so I said to him I said why don't we go
to 30 cities are you crazy so he was
like laughing but then I put together
schedule and for 30 cities in 30
days and I was crisscrossing America I
was going from 90 degree temperature in
Miami up to Minnesota that was like you
know below zero so it was literally like
100 degree temperature differences in
the same day so this is how much I
crisscrossed this country and it was
absolutely fantastic we w a bestseller
list he sold you know 250,000 hard
covers or whatever it was and it was
like a total smash as a bodybuilding and
fitness book and so this is again over
and over again I've seen that not just
the willpower to succeed but to be able
to sell and to communicate and to be out
and actually talk about it you know uh I
think it's important to let people know
when I look in the mirror I
see and uh you know what and and and and
uh and I I also have to tell you this is
another important thing that is to to be
mentioned even the day when I won the Mr
Olympia
competition for the sixth time I won it
seven times all together I know but I
remember the sixth time I was in South
Africa I won the Mr Olympic competition
and then I went home afterwards and I
looked in the mirror and I said to
myself I mean I've so much further to go
it's just I I'm I'm still the skinny I'm
still this is the wrong and this is
wrong and and I was very critical and I
ask myself how did this body ever win
this competition and so this is I I
think what it is is that I'm very
critical of myself and this is I think
the very thing that motivated me always
to be better because it was never kind
of good winning one Mr Universe then
right away you say yourself no I cannot
really sit in this laws and celebrate I
to go for the second one for the third
one for the fourth for the fifth and
miss the Olympia miss the world Miss
International blah blah blah blah and
all this kind of stuff it's kind of like
the I talk about this guy Hillary that
is the first one to climb Mount Everest
and then he's up and on the top and he
looks over and he sees another Peak and
he says oh I have to figure out how to
go and Conquer that Peak and so it just
keeps going and keep going and keep
going and I I think it makes life
exciting but you are much more critical
about yourself yes where did this title
come from be useful it comes from my
father you know he would always say
that and his whole attitude always was
whatever you do try to serve the people
try to do something good for your
community or for your family don't just
think about yourself that's why my
father was so heavily kind of against
body building because he felt like that
what he was called This is sub thr m
self throning which means you're kind of
like glorifying and you're treating
yourself rather than worrying about
others and so he just felt like he says
instead of lifting for yourself why
don't you go out and chop some
wood why don't you go and Shuffle some
coal and this way you help some older
person that has coal delivered Shuffle
coal into their basement so they have C
in the window and they have wood in the
window and you help an order person that
doesn't that is not able to do those
things anymore that's what you should do
then you get also muscles then you also
get strong then you also can can kind of
look good I think that in
general I think what the
book is trying to do is to say to
people you need to
work on
yourself if you just try to be pampered
and if you're trying to be
soft and if you're trying to be the
victim and all of you're not going to go
anywhere we need to get
stronger we need to get Bossier we need
to get
tougher we need to not be afraid of
failure we got to go and do the work we
got to face adversity adversity breeds
character the strength and fighting and
resistance does not only make the muscle
grow but it makes also your head grow
makes you a stronger person we have to
be willing to go through hardship
through suffering through pain through
crying periods all of that stuff don't
shy away from any of that because it
just makes you stronger and I think
today lot of times our youth is so into
kind of oh let's make him feel good oh
no let's be more sensitive well I
totally agree with you to be sensitive
about things but I mean there's also a
sweet
spot can we go too
far you know it's like when someone says
well today I just need to sleep in it's
said bull yeah you don't need to sleep
in this country was not built on
sleeping in so let's get up in the
morning and let's get on that bike and
let's do some exercise and don't even
think about it don't look at your email
or anything like this let's just get
going boom boom boom let's get going
let's start building and so that's the
idea is just not to be overly soft and
overly kind of like sensitive and
everyone is in the victim kind of a
thing I just don't buy into that but you
have to understand that every person has
to be approached also
differently it's like uh the mind is
just like the body I cannot give you
exactly the same training routine that I
had because your body is different what
is the significance of Shifting Gears
shifting gears like to give you an examp
I talked about it earlier ear you wake
up from a surgery that you think is 2
hours they replace your heart valve and
then someone tells you we Pok through
your heart wall and you now have been
out for 16 hours and now you have to
stay here six days of seven days and you
know we you're not out of the woods yet
you know we have to do everything we can
to keep you alive and you know you
almost died on the operating table and
it could still happen next night you
know if you don't really get going with
the walking
and if you get pneumonia so that you
have to shift gears very quickly I
usually call it the art of improvisation
you know that you have to be very good
in improvising because there's a lot of
things that come up to you in life but
you have to be really good in
improvising and this happened to me all
the time when I was governor had to
quickly shift gears and it happened also
in show business where you have to shift
gears but is the unexpected is happening
and you have to be kind of like ready
for that and confront that I mean that's
the most important thing so it's just
it's just so many people get stuck on
certain things on the track and they
then cannot get off the track I just
always felt like I was very good in
shifting gears like going
from bodybuilding to show business I
mean you really had to shift gears
because all a sudden certain other
things became important I mean think
about it you go and you do bodybuilding
every athlete always tells you that you
got to go and keep the emotions out of
the way because it's the emotions that
going to kill you you got cannot go
train and compete and train for a
competition for a world championship or
the Olympic Games or whatever it is and
be emotionally involved in whatever it
is you know because he can derail you so
okay so you do that and have become a
master in that I became like c a
stone but then then all a sudden you go
and you start taking acting
classes and you
start hearing from the acting
teacher
Arnold you talk like a cold
fish there's no emotions there I got to
go and find your
emotions so think about that for a
second all your life long you hear now
that this is
like
and now all a sudden you here you have
to be more emotional you have to be in
touch with your
emotions have you thought about lately
the smell of a
rose I said the smell of what the
rose
says a rose smells a certain way it's a
beautiful
smell says what does this have to do
with acting he says Ah
he says if you sit there on the
scene and you start thinking about that
smell of a rose you have a totally
different facial
expression you close your eyes you know
let's assume that you want to compliment
the woman the perfume she
wears you can't go and says I like your
perfume it's stupid but if you go and
say
what are you
wearing
oh it smells
wonderful I mean you have good taste you
know he says that's a totally different
T he says it would change your voice if
you smell the rose it would change your
voice but you only can do that if you
really smell it and be in touch with
that so that's what I'm talking about
shifting gears very quickly so from one
year to the next I had to kind of all a
sudden have have all the emotions kick
in yeah and make everything work that
didn't really work in the past I think
you know everyone um
has uh their own list of things a bucket
list of things that they always wanted
to do I mean for me I always say said to
myself I think it would be great if I
would have enough time one time to just
sit here and watch all the documentaries
that I always wanted to watch you know I
watch documentaries and I watch watch
movies and I watch the news and all of
this stuff but you always feel like
there's just so much out there so much
content out there that you would like to
kind of see and uh so but everyone has
different needs some people feel like oh
my my my wish list always was to spend
more time with my family so then that's
what you should do you know play with
your if you're old like my age you you
play with your grandkids maybe or with
your kids or uh you know and and have a
good time that way
um and hang out with your parents if you
still have parents and all this stuff so
everyone has a different kind of a wish
list of things that they wish they could
do one of the things that you learn in
sports is that if you just get stuck in
your own training routine and not learn
from other people that you would never
become a champion and uh so
open-mindedness was very important to me
and so I think like I said in my book I
learned a lot of my lons from Sports and
to meet that kind of like and having
people like Freddy GLE uh that Mentor
that talked about open-mindedness and
learning from others and um where you
start as you get older you start
thinking about all of those things
because you become wiser first it
doesn't mean anything when he told me
that this is what the Nazis did arold
they took my brother's head and they
smashed it in with a
stone they stoned him to death and I was
lucky to be able to escape and blah blah
blah and all this stuff so you hear that
that didn't mean anything you know uh I
that's really sad but then it those
those kind of stories as you grow up
yeah and as you get older they mean
something to to you and all of a sudden
you find yourself fighting for
inclusion and against
Prejudice and you ask yourself where
does that come from the desire ofice
said it comes from stories like that you
know that you remember from way back
when people tell you those kind of
things so to me it was always kind of
like learning new things and uh being
able to uh the more you become a
celebrity to be able to use that
celebrity power for something positive
for something good the other thing is is
that you get to work your butt off
um if you think that you're going to go
and accomplish something really special
and be the best in anything in the world
and you think you can do it without
working you make a big mistake because
no matter what I did if it was in
bodybuilding or in acting or if it is in
the political Arena uh it always took a
lot a lot of work and you got to boot
out and you got to you know sometimes
make a lot of sacrifices notice if
you're not willing to work hard forget
about it so is another rule that is a
very important important the bottom line
is that you can train any time of the
day we learned it very quickly and so I
kind of continued on with the tradition
I did two hours of working out in the
morning and then 2 hours in the evening
and that
routine was automatic I didn't even
think about it my entire time in my
bodybuilding career I always trained
twice a day and never ever did I ask
myself the question should I go today
and do the evening training or should I
get up in the morning I always get up at
5: 5 6:00 always and at 7:00 it worked
out I wanted to move on and I knew there
was acting that I wanted to get into but
again I faced the same obstacles where
people said it can't be done when I
talked to agents and they said to me you
cannot become just an act and walk in
the movies I say I just don't want to
become an actor I want to be a leading
man they say well forget about that and
they laughed I mean with your accent no
one has become a leading man with your
accent and with your body look at all
those bumps sticking out
this overdeveloped part they were in 20
years ago when they did Hercules movies
but now it's Dustin hufman it's alino
it's Woody Island there are the new sex
symbols don't you understand it look at
you forget it it will never happen and
with your name schwartzen schnitzel or
whatever your name is I can see that
already up there on the billboard that
isn't going to sell any tickets but you
know something I didn't listen to them I
started working very hard just like in
bodybuilding five six hour hours a day
went to acting classes speech classes
dialogue classes accent removal classes
everything that you can think of I did
and slowly everything started happening
all of those liabilities that they
talked about started turning into assets
when it did Con on the Barbarian the
director came to me and he said if we
wouldn't have you we would have had to
build
one and then Terminator the director
said I couldn't imagine to have anyone
play Terminator that wouldn't have an
accent and they wouldn't have your
body I cannot imagine the line I'll be
back with a normal American accent it
works so perfectly that you have this
German accent so all of those things
that they say the liabilities became an
asset the my moment as moment went on I
they grew and grew and I went from one
movie to the next started making more
and more money and then on end I ended
up being the highest paid actor with $30
million and Terminator 3 I think another
one is this not don't be afraid to fail
uh because if you're afraid to fail then
you're always holding yourself back
because you're afraid that if you go all
out you may fail well in weightlifting
we learned that very quickly the only
way you could break a record is if
you're willing to fail that's when you
put on more weight you try it sometimes
you maybe don't you would not be able to
lift it uh which has happened to me many
times but eventually when you train hard
enough you will lift it so don't be
afraid to failure I mean how can you
fall can't be done this is why I try to
tell you anything and everything can be
done if you can visualize it and if you
believe in yourself it was the same
thing again when I ran for governor you
can imagine when I went on a the night
show and I announced that I'm going to
run for governor of the great state of
California people came to me afterwards
and says you're crazy you don't announce
something like this on a Tonight Show
you have an official press conference at
the state capital plus you don't start
with governorship you go would start
first with mayor or with state senator
and I said I don't want to be Senator I
don't want to be mayor I want to be
Governor don't you understand
that well the rest is history I won in
2003 and I won also in 2006 let me tell
you you're going to find the naysayers
in every turn that you make don't listen
just visualize your goal know exactly
where you want to go trust yourself get
out there and work like hell and break
some of the rules and never ever be
afraid of failure when I used to do
seminars on how to become a champion I
uh would always ask people why do You
Want To Be A Champion or what do you
want to accomplish why are you training
and they will if if a guy will get up
and he would say well I want to train
because I think that if I get
muscular and um you know I feel like I'm
getting the kind of definition then I'm
maybe can enter a bodybuilding
competition I said sit down and if you
think this way you're going to be a
loser you're never going to make it
because there's no maybe you got to get
up and say I want to be a
champion and I do whatever it takes the
amount of hours it takes the posing the
this the that the visualization looking
at training footage looking at
motivational books reading this read
whatever it takes I would do that's the
answer I want to hear from you you can
detect right away those that are going
to be shaky and that will fall behind
and they will not go all the way and
those that are very hungry and that
hunger you have to develop because you
have to create a goal for yourself
whatever that may be a short-term goal
and a long-term goal and you got to go
after that if you do not see it and if
you do not believe it who else will
experiencing uh pain in your muscles and
aching and just then go on and go on and
then go on and this last two or three or
four repetitions that's what makes
actually the muscle then grow and that
divides them one from a champion and one
from not being a champion if you can go
through this pain barrier you make it to
be a champion if you can't go through
forget it and that's what most people
like is on this having the guts the guts
to go in and just say I go through and I
don't care what happens you know it
aches and if I fall down I I have no
fear of fainting in a gym because I know
it's it could happen I threw up many
times while I was working out but it
doesn't matter because it's all worth it
you had an early meeting with Dino
deenus and it didn't go so well well
that was different because din delen at
an office and he wanted me to be in dark
Savage and he wanted me to play the
villain in dark Savage and I walked in
and I always kind of you know have a a
mouth that sometimes goes a little bit
too fast and uh I step on
myself it's it's I walked into the
office and I saw Dino standing behind
his desk and it was this huge desk orate
with gold and kind of like French
looking or Italian looking I don't know
what but it was gigantic it was one of
those partner desks right and Dino the
only thing that stood out was kind of
his chest and his head because he's a
little guy you is a really short guy so
I looked looked in I walked in his
office and I looked in say hi Dino why
does a little guy like you need such a
big
desk
and to dines you never say you're little
right because he saw himself as a giant
so he looked at me and he says Ah aeger
you have an accent I cannot use you
ah and I said again
stupidly who is talking about having an
accent I me look listen to
you ah you're a Nazi ah you know he
walked away he walked away because I had
a German accent so that was the end of
that so I left the office and my agent
came up to me grabbed me really forceful
by my arm and he said to me he says I
been an agent for 15 years this meeting
was exactly 1 minute and 14 seconds it
was the shortest meeting they've ever
had you just everything up God damn it
it took me months to get in here so he
was mad at me also so anyway so that's
so that's how relationship started with
Dina but then when he bought
Conan he came to Spain where we were
shooting and the third day of filming
after he saw the dailies the footage
that we filmed he came up to me and he
said you a Conan ah and he walked off
and and millions came to me the director
and he says this is the greatest
compliment that he can ever get he said
you're Conan isn't that great I guess so
and from that point on we created this
really great relationship and we did
movies together and Raw Deal and then
red Sonia and Conan the Destroyer and
con the and and and he was became kind
of like a father figure he became kind
of the r Park that I had in in a
bodybuilding World in Joe weeder uh he
became that character in the movie world
that I could go to for anything who
would give me advice who always had
wonderful compliments and kind of took
me in as part of his family and so
that's why I always will miss him very
dearly after he passed away you a
fantastic direct response marketer with
your mail owner business can you talk
about the dollar into two concept well
you know we all pay
taxes and we all hate the idea that
you're losing that money but there's a
difference between uh hating that you
lose that money and hating to pay taxes
I love paying taxes if it is the fair
amount and if it is used wisely I think
we all have to contribute it because
that's how you set up Social programs
that's how you build infrastructure
that's how you have a military and all
those kind of things so that that's
great but I always had the belief that
the money that I paying taxes I want to
make up through wise Investments so this
is why I got into real estate right away
in the 70s and I started buying raw land
um and developing that uh started buying
apartment buildings and uh you know just
think about it I mean we in in I
remember in 1974 I bought my first
apartment building and uh we bought it
for
$215,000 that's was then a lot of money
yeah and uh I put only down like maybe $
$337,000 but within 2 years the
apartment building was worth instead of
the $ 215
$350,000 and assort it so imagine now
how much gain there was right I mean so
did we made hundreds of percent of my
initial investment so that's what I'm
talking about so it's it takes uh you
know thoughts and uh ideas can make much
more money than actual physical labor MH
and physical labor is always part of the
action because I always say you got to
work your ass off no matter what you do
because now you have a great idea but
then you still have to implement it and
you have to hassle you have to go to the
bank and you financial statement do this
and that and they raise money sometimes
and you go to look at a thousand
apartment buildings to find the right
one and all those kind of things so you
still have to work but normally if it
just physical labor you can never make
the money then you can make when you
have ideas so this is why it's important
I always tell people I say the secret is
is there's certain times don't think
like when you get up in the morning
don't think just roll out of bed go in
your life cycle or go on a basically
right or go to the gym work out you know
that's what you have to do and then read
something and learn something so don't
even think about it but there's other
times where you have to really think and
you really have to get creative and have
a clear vision of where you want to go
and what you want to do and that's what
I always had and that's what I always
believed and always believed in making
money so that then you can do something
with that you invest in it in orders
eventually you create a family you give
some of your kids and all that stuff but
also for charity look I have the the
Schwarz Institute at USC so we have to
raise money all the time and make money
to to to pay for that and and to support
that we have the R20 the environmental
organization well any organization and
any de is great but if you don't have
the money you can Implement anything and
so this is why it is important that if
is an environmental organization or if
it is my after school programs that are
nationwide where we raise millions and
millions of dollars every year or if it
is just you know living in a great great
Mansion or driving a nice Bentley in the
Bugatti you know those the kind of
things it takes money to do all this
kind of stuff so therefore I believe in
making $1 in the two and having a good
time when I pay my taxes so when someone
says you says arold I say we have bad
news you owe $15 million in taxes I say
wow yes and then they look at me says
why are you happy
about because that means we must have
made a lot of money you have to pay that
much money in taxes and they said yeah
that's the way look at it you say that's
the way I look at it the body is very
important but the mind is more important
in the body we have to visualize what
that body ought to look like in order to
make it win because that's what creates
then the will the will that you need to
go to the gym every day the will that
makes you go into the four stps the will
that makes you go beyond and you do your
500 lb reps in the squats and you can't
do another rep and your body is shaking
it's the will that makes you go one more
time down and struggle up one more time
and so it's all of this so the mental
aspect that motivates you and that makes
the difference between you being in the
gym full of joy and looking forward to
doing that extra rep and looking forward
to doing those extra 100 reps in the
situps and working past the pain period
that or is the mind that's not the body
so this is why I think the body is very
important but the mind is more important
than the body what do you think the
biggest LIF hinging moment was for you
that you didn't see
coming well I think that it
was uh
probably running for governor wow and um
you know there was kind of always the
debate about you know should I run or
shouldn't I run and um my wife didn't
want me to run my kids didn't want me to
run um and so you know I kind of settled
in into that that I'm not going to run
and then um
Chay Leno called me one day and said hey
you want to come on a show next week and
um you know kind of talk about what your
decision is you going to run for
governor in this recall election or
you're not going to run whatever the
decision is just come on the show and
and talk about it and um uh that
morning
um Maria slipped a piece of paper out
the door of the bathro
room and it said two paragraphs on
it one of them said in case you're not
running say
this and in case you decide to run say
[Music]
this so I said to myself wow she expects
one or the other so she's not like 100%
against that M mhm and a lot of other
things have of course transpired in the
meantime that dick Reon kind of told me
that he doesn't want to run that I
should run he doesn't have the fire in
the belly and all those kind of those
kind of things and uh so anyway I took
this note and I said to myself okay that
means that I have to make up my mind now
and on the the night show when I was
sitting there m and the Chena asked me
that
question I then made the decision right
there right then and there and I said
I'm going to run for for governor of the
state of California so this is how that
happens it was one of this decision
people should just
realize that I'm not going to have any
sympathy for any of those things you
know when someone say it's difficult
because there is a lot of things in life
that are difficult and you have to ask
yourself the question right off the top
you know are you going to be one of
those guys that are going to go and back
off every time something is difficult or
do you want to be one of those guys that
says look doesn't matter if it's easy or
difficult almost difficult I'm going to
go and crash through it that's me that's
the person that I want to be and I'm
going to prove it to myself and I'm
going to prove it to the rest of the
world so yet there are certain things
that are difficult there's difficult for
people to have a routine but they just
have to go and do that and they should
just work on it where they go and do
something very simple I'm going to go
and get up every morning at let's say an
hour early before they normally get up
and just work on that and then the next
time they work on it and say okay I'm
going to get up early and I'm going to
go and make my coffee or my tea or
whatever and I'm going to read papers
even though maybe I haven't read the
paper yet in the last 10
years just add that to you and don't
even ask about it should I should or not
that's the key thing about the routine
is that you don't ask yourself should I
or should shouldn't I you just do it in
order to be
complete
and that's when you really have a 100%
chance at being successful when you have
a complete situation that means that you
have developed your body meaning your
health your strength your energy and all
of that makes you much more positive
right because that's when you wake up
when you feel strong and you feel fit
and you ride the bicycle in the morning
ah you know the whole world looks much
more bright so that the training of the
body extremely important the training of
the Mind extremely important this why I
say the people I say you got to educate
yourself you got to read something every
day you got to learn a new language you
got to just always improve and look at
what can you do to improve your business
or your life in general so to develop
the mind and then to develop the
spiritual side and the Soul extremely
important also so if we put those three
things together we have total completion
and this is why the physical training
and I'm not talking about wanting to win
Mr Olympia no we're talking about just
take some light weights and do your reps
pump up the body you know and get some
blood in there then go and run go and
run the stairs go and exercise go to a
yoga class um do some weight training or
when you have kids go out and play
sports you know just you know go
football playing and go soccer playing
and Tennis playing and this whatever you
can that is what creates kind of life in
you and therefore more enthusiasm and
you have a much more positive outlook in
life I have a routine which basically
means they do something we don't have to
think much if at
all like uh I believe that a routines
are very
important it's kind of like the
foundation like to a house or to a
building or to anything so that means
like if I get up in the morning part of
my routine is to get up at the morning
let's say
5:00 then I make my
coffee I feed the animals I go and read
the paper go through my iPad see if
there any important messages so that's
part of the routine I don't even think
about that I also part of the routine is
that I have my bike already mounted on
the back of my car I drive down and then
take it off and I drive I ride with the
bike to the gym in the morning around
6:00 or so then I go to the gym and I
work at 45 minutes to an hour so that's
also routine it's always kind of the
same thing you know to do arms and Del
do it one day and the next day the chest
and back and uh you know calves and all
the stuff I do every day in form a
little bit and and abs of course every
day
uh and then it repeats itself and I do
this the whole week and then what this
also routine is that at night I do some
extra cardiovascular work before I have
dinner so I go for in my home gym here I
go upstairs and go for half an hour and
do the arm
cycle and or the dreadmill or uh the ver
the the life cycle or something like
that that is cardiovascular and the idea
is to burn enough calories so that when
I eat dinner then which is very minimal
you know that it is I don't have to
really worry about calories or gaining
weight because the order you get the
faster you gain weight and the more the
body picks up because your metabolism is
slow so you have to be very careful with
that so those are kind of routine things
that I do and you try to add as many of
those routine things uh as possible
because you do them them without ever
thinking about it and that's what we
need to do there are certain things that
we need to do that is supposed to be a
routine uh that's supposed to be kind of
part of your daily schedule without you
having to think about it and uh so
that's basically my my kind of routine
and I'm a big believer in that how did
you allow yourself or how did you
develop that ability that even though
around you there wasn't that much
success there was more stress but you
saw Mr Austrian were able to do that
have you ever figured out what that was
compared to everyone else you grew up
around I just tell you I was very
unhappy yeah I was unhappy with the
reality of what was around me you know
the tough parents and the lack of food
and others had Stakes we didn't have the
money for that Asic we never ate meat
during the week now the day they would
say oh this is really good because he
were vegan as a kid but it was more for
because of a lack of money uh so we
didn't have anything so every where I
looked so I think to me the only way
really was in order to be happy is to
create my own world and to visualize you
know that's why people sometimes read a
lot because they want to escape into
another story or the day they watch
movies to go and to see another to
escape into another story and all stuff
for me that wasn't available you know
first movie I was saw was like when I
was like N9 or 10 years old was not the
common thing in the village where I grew
up to go to movies and I remember there
was this collapsible kind of a seat I
just fell right down on a on on a floor
because I had never even heard of a
collapse was that you have to fold it
down so I folded it down then waited a
little bit and then of course it went
back up again and I went right down on
the the floor so because of that world
that negative world I had to kind of
create my
own world so I was just always
daydreaming of wonderful things because
I was so enthusiastic about you
know achieving my vision and turning my
vision into reality and uh winning one
Championship after the next there was
always excitement and enthusiasm there
so when I went into the gym I put my gym
bag down and I immediately attacked the
weights there was no I mean many times
we started out by doing maybe uh 3 four
five minutes of ab work and it beginning
to warm up you know to do maybe 500 uh
Roman Chair situps or something like
that to warm up and then we got right
into it or we go right into the the
whole thing but I mean it was right away
warm up set then the next way up next
way up boom boom all the way to the top
until you just can't do it and super
setting everything was always super
setting super setting super setting and
three pumped sets and four sets in a row
five sets in a row so it really it
changed them what exercise we did but it
was always all out and like I said the
training partner was always responsible
to challenge you at all times so there
was the thing I challenge my training
Partners if it was Frank Zayn if it was
Dave Draper if it was Sergio liver
whoever the training partner was in any
given moment we challenged each other
kind of in a fun way but I mean it was
challenged so that you don't slack off
so you don't give yourself a break the
bottom line is and why I like to do
those seminars or those lectures uh or
those motivational speeches or whatever
you may call it is because you can pump
up people and you can really give them
this extra push that they need give them
encouragement uh give them kind of get
them into a positive thinking mode and
all of those things because I know that
I'm a product of exactly that I remember
that when I was 15 years old and picking
up this magazine and reading about R
Park I was so pumped up I went home and
all of the things that I hated at home
and all of the things that I hated in
school all of a sudden disappeared
because now I had a purpose now I knew
where I was going I read it in the
magazine I said this is what re Park did
oh yeah he came from a poor Place leads
it was a factory town it was dirty and
polluted and everything like this and
that's why he grew up that's kind of the
way I grow up here and you know I
followed his footsteps and it worked and
so this is why it is so when he just
just through a
magazine has this kind of a power over
me imagine now if we go there and tell
people life you can do it you can do it
you can be the greatest do it go for it
get the the choer you know whatever I
mean it's like you pump people up and so
this is why I like doing it because uh I
feel like I'm a product of a lot of
encouragement from so many people so I
want to do the same because remember in
the end we I always say we're not judged
by how much we make but we judged by how
much we give back how much do we give so
that's I want to give something
back in the Terminator you have a very
very famous line maybe your most famous
line ever um but you explained it when
you were learning English you didn't
understand contractions you hated them
so you thought the line should be said
differently than it was written so how
would that line have sounded if you'd
gotten your way I will be
back you think right I was as wrong as
anyone can be I was arguing with Jim
Cameron
um Jim Cameron wrote the script and so
that's mistake number one you never tell
a writer that you want to change his
lines and uh we had that battle when we
shot the scene I said look I just think
it sounds funny when I say I'll be
back
I'll it's weird when when I say that and
he said to me says look
Arnold let's shoot it 10 different
ways let's not get hung up should you
say it or not because you are going to
say it because I wrote it and I don't
tell you how to act and you don't tell
me how to write so let's just move
forward let's just shoot it 10 different
ways you know so that's how Jim and I
always talk kind of
straightforward and uh and we shot it 10
different ways close-ups medium shots
long shots uh zoom in shots of
everything you can think of and um and
you know by the time I did say it like
50 times uh with all the different takes
and shots it sounded right to me it
sounded strong to me because it I just
didn't feel like was strong enough and
machine likee enough and uh and uh on
the end you know when I saw it in the
film I was happy that he convinced me to
to say it that way and uh when you say a
line like that you never know if that's
the line that becomes the most famous
line in the movie history and it just
was voted as number one line in movie
history um you don't know that I didn't
even know it was any special at all only
when I promoted the film and I remember
I was in New York and I had people
coming up to me on the street and saying
to me says say
it and I said say what they say the line
the line from Terminator
I said which one come on you know I'll
be back line I said okay I'll be back no
no no just the way you said it in a
movie then I would say I'll be back yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's the one yeah so I
realized then Jesus what did we create a
monster there or something like that it
was like wow it was like a big surprise
to me that it would became such a big
hit and it became bigger as time went on
and um you know the rest is history what
is my morning routine my morning routine
is very simple I get up every morning at
5: in the morning and then I go
downstairs to the kitchen start reading
the various different
[Music]
[Applause]
newspapers and then go in my iPath do
all my emails and stuff
FaceTiming and sound go upstairs to the
gym and work at 45 minutes to an hour do
kardia vascular training that's a great
exercise was key train that
L and after that have my
breakfast stick
around usually it's oatmeal with bananas
and strawberries and some blueberries in
there I mix it all up with some coffee
eat that go and take my shower and then
go to work for some incredible David
goggin motivation check the video right
there next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there when you're suffering you give up
on the very things that you wanted the
most so when the suffering got too much
my dream died and pretty much I almost
died with it if I didn't find Navy Seals